[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen allen die spanische
fernsehkollegin Silvia in sharondo hat
ihren Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern
heute Mittag zugerufen wir ersticken
alle
43 Grad im Schatten für den Norden und
Osten von Mallorca für Teile von
Katalonien und Aragonien gilt die
höchste Stufe des hitzealarms Alarmstufe
Rot auch in 20 Städten in Italien von
Bozen im Norden bis Palermo auf Sizilien
die Hauptstadt Rom hat ihren bisherigen
Hitzerekord übertroffen
41,8 Grad heute in Griechenland kämpfen
sie schon wieder gegen Waldbrände
die Auswirkungen sind gravierend auf
Menschen Wirtschaft und Umwelt und es
ist noch lange nicht vorbei im Gegenteil
die Weltorganisation für Meteorologie
sagt diese schnell aufeinander folgenden
Hitzewellen werden zunehmend intensiver
und häufiger Andreas Postel
zuallererst geht es um Menschenleben
aber auch die Tiere sind gefährdet bis
zum Eintreffen der Helfer waren sie mit
den Flammen auf sich allein gestellt die
Helfer kommen zu spät wir mussten allein
kämpfen gegen die Flammen
dramatische Szenen auch auf einem
Reiterhof südlich von Athen in Kalifa
die Flammen greifen schnell auf die
ersten Stallanlagen über die Angst dass
den Tieren etwas zustößt ist groß in
letzter Sekunde können die Pferde in
Sicherheit gebracht werden
mit der Hitze kommen die Feuer rund um
Athen kämpfen Rettungskräfte gegen die
ersten Waldbrände dieser Saison in
kovaras und einigen anderen Ferienorten
fressen sich die Flammen rasend schnell
an die Häuser heran
die mietris sarviropolos kann nur noch
zusehen
einige versuchen noch das Haus zu
schützen aber das ist hoffnungslos
der Wind ist sehr sehr stark da kann man
nichts mehr machen
insgesamt 230 Feuerwehrleute sind mit
Löschfahrzeugen und Hubschraubern an
verschiedenen Orten im Einsatz überall
konnten sie die Brände bislang nicht
stoppen Griechenland echt unter der
ersten Hitzewelle dieses Jahres die
Feuerwehr warnt dass angesichts der
Temperaturen und der starken Winde die
Waldbrandgefahr noch einmal deutlich
ansteigen werde anfang der Woche mussten
1200 Kinder aus Ferienlager in
Sicherheit gebracht werden
hitzealarm auch in Italien das
Gesundheitsministerium hat für 20 Städte
die höchste Warnstufe ausgerufen in Rom
wurde mit über 41 Grad der bisherige
Hitzerekord gebrochen heißer ist es nur
noch auf Sizilien in den Straßen von
Palermo schwitzen die Touristen aber
selbst den Hitze gewohnten Sizilianern
macht das Wetter zu schaffen
das größte Problem ist für uns die hohe
Luftfeuchtigkeit ansonsten sind wir ja
daran gewöhnt
es ist so eine drückende Hitze im Haus
dass ich vor die Tür gegangen bin um
etwas Luft zu schnappen
besonders für ältere Menschen kann die
Hitze lebensbedrohlich sein deshalb hat
die italienische Regierung nun einen
hitzeplan vorgestellt dieser Regel die
Behandlung von hitzepatienten in
Notaufnahmen und reaktiviert häusliche
Pflegedienste wer kann flüchtet in
diesen Tagen ans Meer doch mit 26 Grad
verspricht auch das nur wenig Abkühlung
und dabei hat die Hitzewelle am
Mittelmeer ihren Höhepunkt wohl noch
nicht erreicht
ja wie einstellen auf diese Hitzewellen
heute kommt der Vorschlag von
Deutschlands Amtsärzten eine Siesta
einzuführen im Hochsommer so nach
spanische Modell etwa Claudia treidel
Hoffmann leitet die Hochschule Ambulanz
für Umweltmedizin am Uniklinikum
Augsburg berät auch die Bundesregierung
in dieser Sache Frau Professorin guten
Abend guten Abend wie sieht denn aus
ihrer Sicht so eine richtig gemacht
ja die sesta ist dafür da dass wir
Gesundheit erhalten von den Menschen die
eben draußen arbeiten die zwei Millionen
Menschen in Deutschland die auf den
Dächern Arbeiten auf der Straße in den
Feldern und die müssen wir schützen die
Gesundheit schützen und auch natürlich
dafür sorgen dass die keine Unfälle
haben also es geht um Arbeitssicherheit
und es geht um Gesundheit für Menschen
die unter extremer Hitze arbeiten müssen
dann erklären Sie uns doch mal bitte wie
sich diese lang anhaltenden und immer
intensiver werdenden Hitzewellen auf uns
Menschen konkret auswirken eine Studie
sagt ja in Deutschland sterben fast
dreimal so viele Menschen an der Hitze
wie im Verkehr
das ist richtig eine aktuelle Studie hat
geschaut wie viele Menschen in dem Jahr
2022 an Hitze gestorben sind und das
waren 70.000 Menschen in Europa bedeutet
das ist wirklich an signifikanter Anteil
von Menschen die eigentlich nicht hätten
sterben müssen und das bedeutet die
Hitze macht mit uns viel was haben wir
zwei gemeinsam mit meinem mit einem Ei
nämlich dass das Ei wenn wir das Kochen
das Eiweiß weiß wird und das ist etwas
was nicht rückgängig zu machen ist
bedeutet in unserem Körper laufen
Prozesse ab immer nach einem Schlüssel
schlossprinzip und wenn dieses dieser
Schlüssel nicht mehr in das Schloss
passt dann verlaufen eben Prozesse im
Körper auch nicht mehr geregelt ab dann
kommt das Multiorganversagen aber das
ist im Prinzip am Ende vorher werden
Menschen die sowieso krank sind noch
kränker kleine Kinder leiden an der
Hitze und das bedeutet das wirklich die
Hitze Kranke kränker macht und gesunde
einfach grogy und bedeutet wir können
nicht mehr vernünftig arbeiten nicht
mehr in vernünftig denken kostet alles
am Ende Geld das haben sie jetzt sehr
plastisch dargestellt aber die Frage ist
ja sind wir uns alle das Problems
überhaupt bewusst nur 14% der Landkreise
und kreisfreien Städte in Deutschland
haben aktuell einen hitzeaktionsplan was
muss denn da jetzt ganz vorne stehen und
gemacht werden
Offenbach hat er erst gerade eben
verkündet dass wir es einen nationalen
hitzeschutzplan bekommen das ist auch
gut so an erster Stelle ist natürlich
die Aufklärung eben und die Frühwarnung
es kommt eine Hitzewelle und dann eben
auch was bedeutet das für uns und das
bedeutet einmal kurzfristig dass wir
dann natürlich Maßnahmen ergreifen
müssen dass wir Menschen mitteilen
müssen dass sie mit Kopfbedeckung
rumlaufen dass Sie viel trinken dass sie
sich natürlich auch in kühle Räume
retten bedeutet aber auch dass wir diese
kühlen Räume brauchen Auszeichnung von
von kühlen Räumen in Städten bedeutet
aber auch langfristig dass wir auch
Städte schaffen müssen wo wir auch kühl
bleiben können das ist ein wichtiger
Punkt über den sollten wir noch kurz
reden wir müssen hier nur ein paar Meter
von unseren Nachrichtenstudio nach
draußen gehen da ist die Fläche komplett
zu betoniert das kann ja dann nicht die
Zukunft sein oder nein wir bauen heute
als ob wir immer noch im letzten
Jahrtausend leben würden wir müssen
jetzt aber so bauen dass wir in diesen
Räumen auch in 30 40 Jahren noch
arbeiten geben können und genau das
brauchen wir jetzt wir müssen jetzt die
Zukunft
gestalten und wir dürfen uns auch von
diesen Horrorszenarien die wir gerade
gesehen haben nicht lähmen lassen
sondern das als Chance nehmen nämlich
jetzt eine coole Erde zu schaffen coole
Städte zu schaffen das als als wirklich
Motivation was Besseres zu machen eine
gesunde Erde für gesunde Menschen gibt
es da schon Vorbilder gibt es so eine
coole Stadt der wir nacheifern könnten
ach Paris hat schon viel geschafft in
Paris hat Parks geschafft es
sichere Fahrradwege es muss auch der
Mensch muss motiviert werden sich aktiv
zu bewegen weil es gut für uns ist und
für den Planeten diese doppelten
Gewinnsituation gesunde Ernährung für
mich und den Planeten und dann gibt es
auch Singapur zum Beispiel die sagt wir
brauchen nicht ein Park in einer Stadt
sondern die Stadt muss ein Park sein das
also wir haben gute Beispiele den wir
folgen können und die wir einfach so
machen können dass wir was besseres
schaffen und das Argument das alles so
viel kostet ist keins weil das teuerste
was wir jetzt tun können ist nichts
die Stadt der Zukunft die Freude macht
und nicht krank das war Claudia treidel
Hoffmann Frau Professorin herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch heute abend ich
danke Ihnen und ausführliches zum Thema
Hitze und Gesundheit heute ein bisschen
später am Abend bei lashs Cosmos
Gesundheitsrisiko Klimakrise wie heiß
ist zu heiß läuft um 22:45 Uhr hier im
ZDF und dann bleibt natürlich die
menschheitsaufgabe generell etwas zu
unternehmen gegen die Klimakrise vier
bis fünf neue Windräder im Schnitt pro
Tag bis 2030 das war die Ansage von
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz im ersten
Halbjahr dieses Jahres waren es noch
nicht mal zwei die aktuellen Zahlen
heute des Bundesverbands Windenergie es
geht voran aber bei weitem nicht so
schnell wie geplant schließlich Holstein
ist einsame Spitze mit 125 neuen
Windrädern an Land seit Jahresbeginn im
Flächenland Bayern waren es gerade
einmal fünf in Thüringen und Sachsen
kein einziges
so sieht ein Windrad in Originalgröße
aus schon das Maschinenhaus ist ein
Koloss mit dem riesigen Generator wird
darin so viel Strom produziert das
Einrad mehrere tausend Haushalte
versorgen kann
beim Bauen neuer Räder sieht die Branche
aber nach wie vor noch viele Hindernisse
mehr dazu von Peter Böhmer
Wind gibt es im Wittgensteiner Land
wahrlich genug und so investieren die
sein Wittgensteins in Windkraft wenn es
nur nicht so lange dauern würde diese
Anlagen brauchten acht Jahre bis sie im
letzten Jahr endlich standen
die Klimawandel aufzuhalten oder zu
verlangsamen zumindest und jede Tonne
CO2 die wir einsparen können ist eine
ist ist exponentiell gewonnen wir hätten
also schon vor fünf Jahren produzieren
können und das sind wir erst seit jetzt
knapp 12 Monaten acht lange Jahre drei
würden im Idealfall reichen heißt es in
der Branche bei Wittgenstein war das so
erst das artenschutzgutachten Dauer bis
zu drei Jahren je nach Gutachter
Verfügbarkeit Gesetzeslage oder neu
entdeckter dann weitere Gutachten
Schallschutz Windschatten Brandschutz
Wasserschutz noch mal sechs Monate dann
ist der Bauantrag bis zu 12 Monaten
Bearbeitungszeit dann haben die
Beteiligten Einspruchsrecht je nach
klagen noch mal drei Jahre
dann erst Rechtssicherheit Bestellung
der Anlagen Lieferzeit bis anderthalb
Jahre eigentliche Bauzeit 2 bis 3 Monate
ob Vögel durch Rotoren gefährdet sind
der streiten sich die Studien für den
Prinzen ist aber klar wenn Kraft ist
Artenschutz der verzögert wird durch die
Gutachten Kosten pro Windrad 30.000 Euro
also man kann dieses Geld tatsächlich in
tatsächlichen Vogelschutz investieren in
habitatsverbesserung an anderen Stellen
sie verlangsam hier ein Projekt was die
Art schützt nur um ein individuell
möglichen individuellen Vogel zu
schützen klar ist bis 2030 sollen in
Deutschland 15 Gigawatt aus der
Windkraft an Land kommen die Hälfte ist
erst erreicht mit dem derzeitigen Tempo
erreichen wir das Ziel von 115 GB nicht
wir bräuchten um das sich für ein
bisschen besser vorstellen zu können
ungefähr fünf durchschnittlich große
Windräder pro Tag von jetzt bis 20 30
und wir haben eben bisher nicht mal zwei
pro Tag
die Bundesregierung setzt auf
leistungsfähigere Anlagen auf den
teilweisen Verzicht von
artenschutzgutachten auf mehr Windrad
Flächen Politik von oben doch es kommt
auch auf Politik von unten an sagt
milanitschke Geschäftsführer eines
Anlagenbauers unten sitzen oft Bremse
die Gemeinden und die Kommunalverwaltung
sind aus den letzten Jahren gewohnt erst
einmal zu prüfen und nach Möglichkeit zu
verschieden und auch zu verhindern weil
ja in der Vergangenheit die Menschen
auch größtenteils gesagt haben auch
Windenergie wollen wir nicht jetzt wird
sie aber gebraucht wir brauchen ja Strom
also müssen die gleichen Leute jetzt zu
einer komplett anderen Mentalität kommen
150 Anlagen betreiben sie etwa im
Sauerland in Neuenrade dieser Park
brauchte zehn Jahre und wenn
demonströsen Bauteile dann geliefert
werden warten neue Probleme wir können
zum Beispiel in vielen Stellen einfach
von der Autobahn über bedarfsausfahrten
abbiegen und werden schon direkt am vor
Ort und die Autobahn GmbH sagt ach nee
da gibt es ja noch andere Möglichkeiten
das machen wir besser nicht und dann
muss man durch sehr pentin Wege und
anderes durch was viel teurer viel
aufwendiger viel langfristiger ist kann
man sie alle sparen dabei drängt die
Zeit in Wittgenstein brauchen sie
Millionen für Wiederaufforstung der
Borkenkäfer der sich wegen des
Klimawandels dramatisch vermehrt hat
ganze Landstriche zerstört Windkraft als
ökologische Geldquelle wenn du die
Bürokratie nicht wäre
weitere wichtige Nachrichten von heute
die hast jetzt du alleine Übersicht ja
nachdem Russland gestern das
getreideabkommen mit der
ukrake gekündigt hat warnte der kremme
Kiew heute davor die Exporte dennoch
weiter zu führen dies sei ohne
Sicherheitsgarantien riskant sagte
kremmelsprecher Peskow der ukrainische
Präsident selenski hatte sich zuvor für
eine Fortsetzung der Getreide Lieferung
ausgesprochen in der Nacht griff die
russische Armee zu dem die Hafenstädte
und deshalb und nikolaje an das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
sprach von einem Vergeltungsschlag für
den Angriff auf die krimbrücke am Montag
und auch aus dem Nordosten der Ukraine
gibt es heute Meldungen dort soll
Russland einen Vorstoß auf die Stadt
kopiens gestartet haben dort Moskau sind
russische Truppen dort bis zu 2 km vor
gerückt der ukrainische Kommandeur des
Heeres bezeichnete die Lage als
schwierig
die Pannen bei der Bundestagswahl 2021
in Berlin sind seit heute Thema am
Bundesverfassungsgericht dabei geht es
unter anderem darum in wie vielen
Berliner Wahlbezirken die Abstimmung
wiederholt werden muss aus Sicht der
Union müssen es mehr sein als vom
Bundestag mit den Stimmen der
ampelfraktion beschlossen deshalb legten
CDU und
csu-wahlprüfungsbeschwerde ein bei der
Bundestagswahl am 26 September 2021 war
es in Berlin zu langen Warteschlangen
vor Wahllokalen gekommen es gab zu
wenige Wahlkabinen falsche und fehlende
Stimmzettel und zum Teil Stimmabgaben
nach 18 Uhr
die Pflege im Heim ist deutlich teurer
geworden das meldet der Verband der
Ersatzkassen Grund sein vor allem
gestiegene Personalkosten durch höhere
Löhne in der Pflege im Schnitt Zahlen
Pflegebedürftige und ihre Familien im
ersten Jahr monatlich
2548 Euro und 350 € mehr als noch vor
einem Jahr immer mehr Menschen könnten
sich das nicht mehr leisten war der
Verband
der seit drei Jahren untergetauchte
ehemalige wirecard-vorstand Jan Marshall
Leck hat sich mit Hilfe eines Anwalts
beim Landgericht München eins gemeldet
ein Gerichtssprecher bestätigte den
Eingang eines Schreibens zum Inhalt
äußerte er sich allerdings nicht das
Landgericht verhandelt seit einigen
Monaten über den mutmaßlichen Milliarden
betrug bei Wirecard marschale gilt als
Schlüsselfigur und war als ehemaliges
Vorstandsmitglied für das Asiengeschäft
des Unternehmens verantwortlich
in Israel hat es in mehreren Städten
erneut Proteste gegen die umstrittene
Justizreform der rechtsreligiösen
Regierung gegeben in Tel Aviv
blockierten tausende demonstrierende
wichtige Straßen und die Börse die
wollen den Druck erhöhen da das
Parlament noch vor der Sommerpause über
einen Teil der Reform abstimmen will
mehrere Menschen wurden festgenommen bei
seinem Besuch in Washington betonte
Israels Präsident Herzog die Demokratie
seines Landes sei gesund stark und
widerstandsfähig
zwischen Europas verbrieftem Asylrecht
und der gelebten tatsächlichen
Asylpraxis klafft ein ziemlicher
Unterschied er wird geprägt von
kollektivem wegschauen und Abweisen von
lebensgefährlichen Fluchtrouten einem
Wettlauf übers Meer der so oft tödlich
endet aber auch von geringen
anerkennungs- und abschiebequoten und
gezielte Missbrauch egal aus welcher
politischen Ecke man darauf schaut
zufrieden mit der aktuellen Situation
kann wohl niemand sein der CDU-Politiker
Thorsten freie parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der Unionsfraktion hat
jetzt einen weitgehenden Vorschlag
gemacht kein individuelles Recht auf
Asyl mehr dafür Kontingente für die
Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen in Europa es
wäre das Ende des Grundrechts auf Asyl
es ist auf jeden Fall der Beginn einer
Diskussion bei der sich frei auch viel
Kritik anhören muss Klaus Brodbeck
Menschen die alles riskieren um Europa
zu erreichen die Gründe vielfältig Krieg
Hunger Verfolgung und die Hoffnung auf
ein besseres Leben gebündelt in einem
Wort Asyl das will der Vorschlag nun
ändern tatsächlich ist es so dass ich
meine dass man aus dem Individualrecht
des Asylrechts eine sogenannte
Institutsgarantie machen müsste und das
bedeutet im Klartext dass man keine
individuellen Rechtsansprüche mehr hat
sondern dass Europa sich entscheidet
eine bestimmte Zahl von vulnerablen
Menschen in Europa aufzunehmen
Kontingente würden politisch festgelegt
wie viele aus welcher Krisenregion 300
bis 400.000 pro Jahr für ganz Europa
bisher findet frei begünstigten
Asylrecht und Praxis oft falsche weil
diejenigen zu uns kommen die jungen
stark häufig männlich gesund sind und
die Möglichkeit haben 10.000 € für einen
Schlepper zu bezahlen
erste Reaktionen durchaus erwartbar von
Entsetzen bis Empörung
im Ergebnis ist der freivorschlag
genauso
radikal wie die Vorschläge der AFD er
hat am Anfang so ein bisschen humanitäre
es läuft Feuer gibt der ab aber die
Konsequenz
er ist außerhalb des Grundgesetzes da
gibt es eine Menschenwürde Garantie ich
glaube dass Herr Frey mit dieser
Forderung versucht am ganz ganz rechten
äußeren Rand zu fischen ich rate
dringend dazu gerade der CDU und Herrn
frei dringend dazu zur Besinnung zu
kommen und sich nicht bei der AFD
anzuwanzen der Höhenflug der AFD sei
Anlass für freies Vorstoß sie selbst
wolle das aktuelle Asylrecht nur anders
anwenden sagt die AFD reichlich Häme
inklusiv
ich denke die Union mit ihrem
Aufmerksamkeitsdefizit und mit ihrem
Hauptgegner den sie als solchen
empfindet AFD möchte ein bisschen im
Wähler Reservat der AFD Fischen und sich
deshalb migrations thematisch ein wenig
bemerkbar machen ich glaube das eine der
zentrale Fragen in der Wahrnehmung der
Menschen die Migrationsfrage und die
Lösung der damit verbundenen
Herausforderungen ist und es ist die
Aufgabe von Politik und Politikern dafür
sich Gedanken zu machen kurz mal
nachgelesen aus einem Bundestag
Grundgesetz Artikel 16 er gehört zu
denen die nie verändert werden dürfen
politisch Verfolgte genießen Asylrecht
also das Grundgesetz ist praktisch in
diesem Punkt hat es an seiner Relevanz
verloren zu gering die Anerkennungsquote
sagt frei lieber nichts dazu und doch
viel sagt die Außenministerin
offensichtlich sind wir schon im
Sommerloch
das aber könnte durchaus bedeuten die
Debatte hält an ein schönes zusammen
ja schneller Analyse dazu noch von Theo
Colin Berlin genannt theo ist das jetzt
Einzelmeinung von Thorsten Frey oder
Teil einer ganz gezielten
unionsstrategie nein das ist ganz
eindeutig keine Einzelmeinung es kommen
ja schon erste wichtige unterstützende
Stimmen aus der Union und natürlich ist
das vorher mit der Partei und
Fraktionsspitze abgesprochen auch wenn
Friedrich Merzig heute dazu nicht
geäußert hat Thorsten frei ist der
durchaus mächtige parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer der unionfraktion und
damit quasi die rechte Hand von
Friedrich Merz im Bundestag und er hat
die Signale ja offensichtlich bewusst
sehr lautstark gesetzt das Asylrecht
Gründer auf einer Lüge schreibt der er
spricht von Heuchelei und dass die
Belastungsgrenze der Bevölkerung
überschritten sein also da wird ganz
klar ein Thema in den Fokus gerückt das
in allen Umfragen auch wirklich für die
Menschen aktuell eines der wichtigsten
ist und wenn man es in Kombination sieht
mit dem Vorschlag des designierten
cdu-generalsekretärs zu den schnell
Verurteilungen von Freibad Tätern dann
präsentiert sich da gerade eine CDU
durch harte Ansagen jetzt sagt frei aber
auch selbst auf dem Weg gebe es enorme
Hürden wie viel Chancen hat denn der
Vorschlag dann auch tatsächlich
verwirklicht zu werden ehrlich gesagt
keine jedenfalls aktuell sind die
Chancen der Verwirklichung nicht
existent selbst wenn die
Ewigkeitsklausel nicht für das Asylrecht
gilt oder gelten sollte dann braucht die
Union für eine Änderung des
Grundgesetzes eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit
und die gibt es nicht sPD Grüne FDP und
Linke haben sich ja alle schon gegen den
Vorschlag ausgesprochen das ist in einem
politischen Profi wie Torsten frei aber
natürlich vorher klar gewesen insofern
kann man es je nach politischer
Perspektive entweder als überfälligen
Debatten Beitrag zum sagen wir
ungelösten Flüchtlingsproblem sehen oder
als strategisches wahlweise
populistisches blinken an die mit der
AFD liebäugelnden Wähler möglicherweise
erleben wir da gerade bei der CDU das
Schärfen von politischen Kanten sagte
Paul vielen Dank
und hier noch mal du Hannah die
Lohnlücke zwischen Ost und westdeutschen
ist im vergangenen Jahr gewachsen
ostdeutsche Arbeitnehmer verdienten im
Schnitt rund 13.000 Euro im Jahr weniger
als westdeutsche das geht aus einer
Anfrage der Linksfraktion im Bundestag
beim Statistischen Bundesamt hervor die
Lebenshaltungskosten in ostdeutschen
Bundesländern lagen in der Vergangenheit
allerdings unter dem bundesweiten
Durchschnitt
wer eine Wohnung mieten will oder einen
Kredit abschließen möchte hat früher
oder später mit der Schufa zu tun und
die will nun transparenter werden über
eine neue App sollen Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher künftig kostenlos Ihren
schufa-basis Score abrufen können
allerdings gibt durchaus Kritik an dem
neuen Angebot warum die Schufa hat ja
den Ruf eine Datenkrake zu sein und
kritiker fürchten nun dass die Auskunft
Teil durch die Erdball noch mächtiger
werden könnte ja worum geht's künftig
kann man per App seine schufa-bewertung
abrufen und wird proaktiv auch mit einer
Push-Nachricht über negative Einträge
informiert das soll über die
Finanzplattform bonify funktionieren die
die Schufa vergangenes Jahr gekauft hat
etwa 13% der Menschen in der Schufa
Datenbank haben eine eher schlechte
Bonität und gerade sie könnten sich bald
gezwungen sehen zu viele Daten von sich
preiszugeben denn über die bonify App
kann der Schufa auch Einblicke ins
eigene Konto gewähren laut Auskunft high
kann das helfen die eigene Bonität
aufzupult polieren freiwillig sagt die
Schufa wenn man aber den Kredit
unbedingt haben möchte gibt man diese
Daten eher weiter und das wäre dann
nicht ganz so freiwillig nun gibt es
aber auch ganz unabhängig von der neuen
App Kritikpunkte an der Schufa vor allem
mit Blick auf die Berechnungsmethode
genau das hat mit dem Thema Transparenz
zu tun man weiß die Bonität berechnet
sich aus verschiedenen Faktoren aber
welche genau das sind und wie die
gewichtet werden das hält die Schufa
geheim kritiker sagen das ist eine
riesige Blackbox wie die Schufa die
Daten verarbeitet es müssen eine Menge
sein denn die Schufa hat Informationen
zu 68 Millionen Menschen vielen Dank
Valerie für diese Einordnungen
der Schriftsteller Lutz Seiler hat schon
viele Preise gewonnen nun kommt der
renommierte Georg Büchner Preis dazu die
Deutsche Akademie für Sprache und
Dichtungen lobt ihn als unverwechselbare
Stimme Seiler sei auch als Erzähler
einen klarer wie rätselhafter dunkel
leuchtender Lyriker geblieben hieß es in
der Begründung ausgezeichnet wird er für
sein Gesamtwerk 2014 hatte er bereits
den Deutschen Buchpreis erhalten
bei der Schwimm-WM in Japan haben Leonie
Beck und Florian Wellbrock erneut
triumphiert beide wurden Weltmeister im
Freiwasserschwimmen über fünf Kilometer
nachdem sie zuvor schon Gold über die
doppelte Distanz geholt hatten und auch
die deutschen Wasserspringer gewannen
eine Medaille im Mixed-Team Wettbewerb
vom Turm und 3 m Brett landeten sie auf
Platz drei hinter China und Mexiko
so ein spannendes Kopf an kopfrennen bei
der Tour de France Radsport Freaks
erinnern sich das hat es zuletzt gegeben
als frankreichs Staatspräsident français
und die Berliner Mauer noch stand
Laurent gegen Greg lemont 8 Sekunden
Vorsprung für immer und auf der
Schlussetappe und jetzt wieder zwei
Rivalen und 10 Sekunden Abstand vor dem
anspruchsvollen Bergzeitfahren heute 16
Etappe wir können uns das ganz bequem
hier schon mal angucken wir müssen ja
nicht mitfahren Stefan Bier hat die
beiden Kontrahenten um den Tour Sieg
heute beobachtet
auf der Suche nach der verlorenen Zeit
hat Tal der pogaccia bislang in Sekunden
gedacht 10 Sekunden Rückstand hatte der
slowena auf Jonas doch als er dem Dänen
heute zum Tageslicht gratuliert ist klar
er muss umdenken hat eine neue
Zeitrechnung eingeführt es geht wieder
eher um Minuten
zurückhalten aber ich war immer noch
echt schnell wahrscheinlich einer der
besten Tage meines Lebens auf dem Rad
auf the best days of my life on the bike
ein bis zwei Hände mehr ist bislang
nicht nötig um bei den Abständen
zwischen den beiden über 15 Etappen
hinweg mit zu zählen die 22 km lange
Alleinfahrt gegen die Uhr heute hinauf
nach Kombu verspricht wieder 1 Sekunden
Rennen eine Art Zeitfahren ist bislang
ja auch schon nur Schulter an Schulter
man belauert sich stundenlang mal ist
der eine ein paar Radlängen voraus mal
der andere unterm Strich 10 Sekunden
Vorsprung für den gelben
doch heute ist pokercha beim Rennen
gegen die Uhr nicht schnell genug für
einen Trikot tauscht schon auf dem
ersten flacheren Teilstück ist der Mann
in gelb 20 Sekunden voraus bei dieser
Tour sowas wie eine kleine Ewigkeit
entweder
das ganze in Grenzen halten alles
gegeben
vor dem Anstieg zum Ziel auf ein
leichteres Rad das kostet noch mal 10
Sekunden
spart die Zeit bleibt auf dem etwas
schwergängigeren Zeitfahrrad sitzen
schneller als alle anderen bis auf den
unglaublichen Dänen der eine Minute 38
Sekunden heraus fährt sein Vorsprung in
der Gesamtwertung hat sich auf einen
Schlag fast verzehnfacht doch morgen
kommt die Königsetappe dieser Tour
hinauf nach Kirsche Wellen am expecting
im himmlisch
dran zu bleiben
[Musik]
absolut noch nicht vorbei besonders wenn
es morgen regnet da verspreche ich euch
das wird interessant professionell
weiter in gelb Vorsprung ausgebaut die
Zeit heute sie ist für Jonas singer
gelaufen
ja morgen jetzt gleich nach uns ein
hartes Thema aber ein Film der auch
Hoffnung gibt mit einer ganz tollen
Protagonistin das hat mir die zuständige
zdf-kollegin für 37 Grad heute
geschrieben es ist eine ungewöhnliche
langzeitreportage die nicht nur ihr sehr
wichtig ist ich verrate jetzt gar keine
Details sie bleiben einfach dran
ja und dann noch der Tipp unser heute
journal Update gibt's gegen 0:30 Uhr
Mittag ausser und vom gesamten Team hier
auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter
den Kameras ein angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Hitzewelle in
der Mittelmeerregion setze ich weiter
fort und die Temperaturen liegen
teilweise über der 40 Grad Marke und das
wird auch morgen wieder der Fall sein in
den kommenden Tagen setzt sich die Hitze
dann allmählich weiter Richtung ostwärts
durch und auch Richtung Griechenland
gibt es dann Temperaturen um die 40 Grad
Marke und darüber wir schauen auf die
Nacht in Deutschland und da sind wir im
Süden hier in diesem schraffierten
Bereich da ziehen Gewitter durch die
können Unwetter artig sein teils mit
Starkregen Sturmböen und dazu auch Hagel
ganz im Norden gibt es regen dazwischen
teilweise aufgelockert oder auch stärker
bewölkt aber trocken Temperaturen sinken
auf 10 Grad hier im Osten Richtung
Brandenburg 18 Grad zum Beispiel in
Bayern ja und morgen im Tagesverlauf
ziehen Schauer durch auch mit Blitz und
das ganze bewegt sich nach Osten über
den Mittelgebirgen gibt es einzelne
shower am Tagesverlauf und auch im Süden
kann es bei Schauern auch mal Blitzen
und Donnern ganz im Westen ist es eher
trocken und sonnig Temperaturen dazu bei
höchsten Werten von 18 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und 30 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands die nächsten Tage
ja es gibt weitere shower zum Beispiel
am Donnerstag hauptsächlich in der Mitte
und nach Norden bei 18 bis 29 Grad
Freitag vor allem im Süden Gewitter und
Samstag dann schon etwas Trockner und
damit ein schöner Abend